good morning welcome to what should be
the final day of the cop 26 summit here
in glasgow in theory world leaders have
until six o'clock tonight to reach an
agreement on limiting global warming in
practice the heated debate on lowering
temperatures will spill into the weekend
in all probability the leaders of some
smaller nations are reported to have
complained about a lack of detail on the
state of the talks ashna as you know is
with us she's been here throughout will
it end today
so if you ask the uk presidency if you
ask alok sharma he's going to say it
will end at 6 p.m today that is the
final deadline that he's been given but
some people are saying is he just saying
that to encourage more movement
encourage more ambition and to get
things over the line in reality it looks
very much like saturday and even sunday
could be the day there are lots of
sticking points from this the diplomatic
gloves are off essentially countries are
really in those negotiation rooms
overnight even overnight we were
expecting a another draft agreement
that's called the first agreement of
this final communique but we haven't
been given it and that's delayed now by
some 24 hours so that's the real concern
if we don't have the final communicate
overnight how are countries going to
well agree on something by saturday are
we going to reach this one and a half
degrees keep one and a half alive is
what boris johnson keeps telling us he
does keep saying that but scientists
according to the pledges that have
already been made big movements from
china big movements from india but even
with that it looks as though scientists
are saying we're not going to reach 1.5
we're actually going to limit to 2.4
degrees so at the moment scientists
saying it's not enough what's already
been committed okay lots to talk about
between now and six o'clock tonight or
indeed spilling over to tomorrow let's
see
thank you
meantime the leader of one of the
world's most climate vulnerable nations
has told sky news the commitments at the
glasgow summit here are just
aspirational the prime minister of the
bahamas philip davis says the talks
don't seem to have any teeth and he's
criticized boris johnson's approach to
cop 26. mark stone reports from nassau
in the bahamas
where better to judge the success of the
glasgow summit than the bahamas
because beyond the picture postcard
image this is a low-lying storm-battered
island nation on the brink
how are you
welcome back from glasgow
and its prime minister's assessment of
the world leaders cop commitments is
hardly glowing i invited them to be
brave
to be courageous
and act
because as you said it's a lot of fancy
words they don't seem to have any
teeth to them
it's aspirational
if at the end of this summit this code
red summit they're talking only about
aspirations so is that success or
failure let me put it this way i don't
like i don't want to say success or
failure what i want to say is
progress
has been stagnant
its progress is stagnant
and and i hope that we'll get out of
this
quagmire
the bahamas contribution to global
greenhouse gas emissions is just 0.01
and yet this is where the impact of
warming global temperatures is
existential eighty percent of the land
here is three feet or less above sea
level
and they say the weather is ever more
extreme hurricane dorian in 2019 was one
of the most powerful ever recorded it's
worrying for me because
um our islands are being swallowed right
now by
by rising uh sea levels
and it has to stop
if you're lucky
um we may become refugees
if you are not lucky
you'll be swallowed up with the
rising sea levels
or wiped away by
more and more intense storms
among the prime minister's fears is the
non-binding nature of pledges that are
not promises which could be scrapped as
fast as governments change
i think political change
has been an enemy to success
and we need to find a way and a
mechanism to ensure
that
that political change
will not no longer [ __ ] any progress
it sounds like you're worried that any
progress that has been made could be
undone quite quickly yes
because at the end it is the attitude of
leaders
this is where the conclusions in glasgow
matter now the alternative they say is
that our children will tell theirs there
was once a place called the bahamas
mark stone sky news in nassau
well the leaders of the smallest nations
on earth are hoping the leaders of the
biggest nations will sign a final deal
as early as today joining us now is
sarah graham wilkes jr president of the
republic of palau a group of islands in
the western pacific ocean he was
actually
here
to speak to other leaders earlier on in
the conference hello to you again mr
president thank you for joining us when
you were here you did say to other big
economies that
unless they do more in your words you
might as well bomb
our islands
strong words tell us why you said that
well thank you kate um
first of all
uh you know the reason why i was very
strong in those words is we live it
every day
the
the tides continue to rise
uh we see sea level rise coming into our
homes coming into our our taro swamps
um we see
the winds coming just destroying our
homes just
uh we didn't used to be the thai food
belt now we've had three typhoons in the
last
decade uh and then we've had these
humongous monsoons
that cause tremendous landslides so
we've had landslide issues
and
just
lately now more frequent droughts and
very hot weather which also cause havoc
on our
coral reefs which uh yeah you can see
pictures of our our docks which are now
reefs not uh docks anymore with rays
crashing over
and uh
our coral reefs you know getting coral
bleaching but also
killing our our very uh fragile
jellyfish that are our world uh renowned
and what visitors come to to see and in
in 2015 for three years they disappeared
luckily they're back
but that's
that's the uh the reality that we live
uh the impacts impact our daily lives
not only from
the losing our possible
losing our homes and losing our islands
uh and our territorial boundaries but
also our
economic livelihoods and lastly a
study just came out
that 40 of the fish stock in our area
will be depleted
by 2100 on the current trajectory of of
uh the temperature rise so
uh it really impacts every everything
about our lives on the islands
and it's slow and it's suffocating
that's why i said you might as well bomb
us
yeah um mr president what would you say
to leaders of countries like australia
who say they're still going to expo
export coal as long as people want it
china saying that it's going to be into
the middle of this century before they
can be um climate neutral when it carbon
neutral when it comes
to fossil fuels the same we're hearing
from india and russia and brazil as well
what would you say to those leaders this
morning
well you know
dinosaurs
disappeared because
of a
natural disaster or calamity
climate change is something we can
control
and
you know we don't want people dropping
bombs on other people
why should we allow
this behavior to continue which
invades our islands destroys people's
lives
uh why should that be allowed to
continue if we can make the difference
so really what we're appealing to is
we know the facts we know that
we need to change the trajectory so that
there is hope for our children
and what we're you know what we're
asking and demanding that our that our
partners around the world do is take
action
take action for our children for our
people
uh the
the
future
of our children
uh
looks bleak and they don't see any hope
in it
and in fact in our islands
across the pacific we have some of the
highest rates of suicide in the world
and i always share that that's partly
because sometimes they feel there's no
hope
and i think it's incumbent about the
leaders in australia china and india to
give children
hope
and give our people hope and that's what
we're asking for is please give our
people hope
we know it's hard we all have to make
sacrifices but we can do that if we're
together
just a quick thought mr president if you
would please before i let you go your
90-day
challenge just tell me a little bit more
about that if you would
well
hello is very fortunate to be hosting
the our oceans conference this year uh
on february 16th and 17th of course
we're inviting the world to come
and it's important for us to showcase
the islands and how we are combating
climate change and the issues that we
have surrounding the oceans how we need
to protect them so that they're
sustainable we can
benefit from a sustainable economy how
we
are able to make sure that they're doing
their part in also reducing carbon and
and producing oxygen that we need for
the world so our healthy oceans mean a
healthy healthy planet and
you know
the 90 day challenge has begun because
we are uh
we want people to start making
commitments
uh that they can be able to share at
their oceans conference uh in february
and you know this just is a continuation
of cup 26 we want the momentum to keep
going i know that there's challenges and
hopefully they'll conclude an agreement
today uh
but those challenges we need to find
solutions we need to overcome them and
that's why we're hosting our oceans to
continue those uh address those
challenges come up with solutions and
keep pushing forward
uh throughout the year because we cannot
just let it go and say well this is cop
26 and that's the end no we have to
continue to push the momentum forward to
keep the ball rolling because that is
our only hope of
keeping below 1.5
mr president we must leave it there
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to our viewers on sky news today
and also for sharing your personal
images of your beautiful island and the
challenges that it faces going forward
thank you very much indeed mr president
yeah thank you very much
thank you don't forget you can listen to
all the latest climate news on climate
cast where you normally find your
podcasts
over the last 13 days in glasgow
politicians have talked about the end of
coal whatever that means but for the
poorest people in the world it remains
an essential fuel which they absolutely
depend upon and we've heard what
australia is doing haven't we we've just
heard
from the president of pilada about
exactly what he needs australia to
commit to they say maybe katharine of
autopsy reports from joharia in eastern
indiana
they are here every day from dawn until
dark dodging bulldozers and tipper
trucks for this
what these local villagers want is coal
and they'll trespass onto government
mines to get it
it's terrifying to watch as even very
young children race towards lorries
unloading piles of mine pit debris
sifting through the remains
to steal whatever little chunks of coal
they can find
[Music]
that's 50 pence for this enormous risk
but people do it because they're
desperate
and we spot even more people on their
way
[Music]
[Music]
this is happening in the plain view of
all the people who are officially
working here you know they can see what
is happening and it happens every single
day and although police we are told come
and periodically chase people off
tacitly they accept it because they know
if people aren't allowed to do this
however dangerous it might be they've
got nothing left
despite india's new 2017 net zero date
there's no clear targets for coal
and workers at this mine tell us they've
been told to extract more because
although india has ambitious plans for
renewable energy
lifting millions out of poverty means
power now and lots of it
when the world is saying we've got to
stop burning things we've got to stop
using coal is there a way we can do that
and balance that without sacrificing
these communities
do mining or don't do it mining but they
will do their mining by their own so
without coal
the entire area cannot exist
and as toxic as this air is the
villagers living next to these mines
don't want to move
the coal dust is filthy
clings to their lungs but this is
everything to them
foreign
[Music]
cop leaders tell us the end of coal is
in sight
but here it will place a huge demand on
people
who care more about their family's
short-term survival than the global
climate crisis
[Applause]
is keeping an eye on the climate
dashboard for us in the boxing ring that
you see on the climate show on our
dedicated channel chat to her in just a
second before that let's bring in
katarina should we who's standing by for
us you've been up to your knees and
higher in water over the last few days
good morning katarina what's it like
there today
well as you can see okay still plenty of
water over the city of chennai this is
the sixth day that this south indian
city has been inundated after an intense
bout of rain at the weekend and heavy
rain really ever since and it's simply
not drained away i mean just look this
is a pretty main road through the city
it hasn't stopped some people trying to
get
from one side to the other at least now
it is looking a little bit drier and
it's really now a case of trying to pump
out as much
water as they can and if we head over in
this direction you can see that's
exactly
what's happening state fire and rescue
departments are using these big water
pumps just to try and shift some of the
water because the issue at the moment in
the city and this is the issue for which
state administrators have come under a
huge amount of criticism is that chennai
is a city that is not built for this
sort of extreme weather and we know that
as a result of our warming planet we're
going to see more radical and frequent
shifts in extreme weather things from
extreme heat to extreme rain and we need
cities that are resilient and which can
cope there's been a lot of criticism
here that this city cannot what other
cities can and what can other cities do
to try and prepare to cope for extreme
changes in weather like we've seen in
chennai so that when there is a heavy
village of rain you don't end up with
scenes like this people riding
motorcycles with water coming up to
their feet and over and people simply
unable to get the basics schools have
been shut here there's been tens of
thousands of homes across the state
devastated by these floods it's not over
yet it's the beginning of monsoon season
it's really just a start of a long
period of difficulty for people living
here
okay katarina thanks very much indeed
highlighted here of course as well at
cop 26 where more than 120 countries
leaders
have been meeting over the last 13 days
is this going to be the last day are
they going to reach that one and a half
degrees or certainly in a great watch
the chair there the um one and a half
degrees that they're so promised hello
um
lady who you know ashley has been taking
us through events throughout the last
couple of weeks this is our climate
dashboard behind us is obviously the set
that we normally use if you've been
watching us at all on our climate uh
show our climate channel with um anna
and also with sam tell me about this
though the first one is the temperature
of the earth because it looks a bit
scary when you first look at it so a lot
of numbers numbers but the first one so
since the industrial revolution the
earth is obviously that might switch
times oh i think it is yeah
right yes i think we can we can the
first one is the temperature of the
earth right now so at the moment it's
sitting at around 1.2 degrees the
crucial number though is is it going to
be reached and that limit of 1.5 degrees
but that's been warming since the
industrial revolution the second number
the total number of co2 emissions
currently around the world and look at
it two over two million and what
scientists are really concerned about is
obviously with that increase rising
countries like india parts of the
pacific islands are going to be
destroyed because of those coastal
communities and so many other things are
literally losing losing out to all of
this and the last one is right now
this is as we speak yeah as we speak
this is the amount of power that is
powering
the uk you're the uk so at the moment
look at that no coal is being used at
all that's impressive that is impressive
50 wind i suppose it is quite a windy
day today here in glasgow pretty cold up
here in glasgow people um but 00 solar
because i suppose we are in now in
scotland yeah okay nuclear increasingly
um as well but interesting no co at all
i know you're going to be with us
throughout the programme this morning
thanks very much indeed ashnif now thank
you and on monday night here on sky news
we'll have a special edition of the
great debate for you where we'll be
asking whether world leaders have done
enough or is uh runaway climate change
now inevitable you can email us at the
great debate at sky dot uk to give us
your views and join our virtual audience
that's the great debate with trevor of
course at 9 00 p.m
on monday so as i said this will it be
pulled down uh later on today headley if
you turn around we can have a look how
amazing the earth is when you first come
in to this summit conference or the blue
zone as it's called it really really
captures the attention um we are hoping
that there will be a deal today alok
sharma has told us that the conference
will end at 6 pm this evening others are
not so confident not least because
australia just coming into focus there
has said as far as fossil fuels are
concerned if people want to buy they're
cold mostly coal that's the third
biggest exporter in the world that they
will continue to do so
meanwhile the people that work here they
um are certainly planning for uh pulling
down this these displays uh later on uh
today if you've been watching us
throughout you'll know that these
gentlemen here um have been watering
this living wall
that has that says cop26 this is steve
and he has been doing that throughout
the last couple of weeks what happens to
these plants when it's all over
you know how we've had these cop 26 in
the back of shot throughout the
programme over the last couple of weeks
people like steve have been keeping it
heist yeah what's gonna happen great
work by the way thank you
you've been on the telly more often than
i have um what's going to happen to all
these flowers our plants when you've
done well basically we're going to
recycle them just we're going to take
them out put them into big trees and
then put them in another job somewhere
else maybe in two or three months time
but definitely going to reuse them how
difficult has it been to look after them
it's been quite easy actually because
it's not been too dry and it's not been
too hot so um i think it's just about
perfect but the secret is to keep them
moist every day you know yeah and how
did you choose which plants to use
that's a good question mainly for this
one is sort of colours and plants would
also enjoy a little bit of shade
so you thought this through haven't you
not just thrown together no though
they're not going to be in your back
garden uh no they wouldn't last about
two weeks i don't think not in this
weather for sure good to talk to you
steve thank you great work thank you
recorded that with we recorded that with
steve just a little bit early because we
weren't sure that he was still going to
be here sod's law he is still here today
everybody's just teasing him because
he's been on the telly uh now still to
come as the cop talks enter their final
stage we'll chat with the shadow
minister for international development
labour's preet gill coming up
we'll also be joined by environmental
activists and guardian columnist george
monbiot who has followed every
development over the last 13 days of cop
26.
after scoff and welcome the world to cop
26 we'll talk to the first minister
nicola sturgeon in the next hour
for all of that britney spears could be
freed from the controversial
conservatorship that has controlled
every aspect of her life for more than
13 years a hurrying to decide whether
the order should be ended will take
place in california later on today our
u.s correspondent martha kelner reports
for years now they've campaigned for
their idol to be freed victory for them
and britney spears could be just hours
away
a judge seems poised to end the
conservatorship an extreme legal
arrangement in place since 2008 which
britney herself has compared to slavery
this is a lock box that represents all
the rights that britney has been denied
for 13 plus years and so you'll see she
doesn't have her car key she doesn't own
a passport
medications are not her decision that's
what we've been fighting for for her to
be able to do what she wants and the
fact that it's getting so close i mean
oh my god i just can't believe it i mean
it's
it just feels unreal she's been
controlled for so long even before the
conservatorship so freedom means a lot
of things for brittany but hopefully it
means some peace
britney spears claims that for almost 14
years her every move was controlled she
says a listening device was put in her
bedroom she says security used to
administer her medication she even says
her phone communications were constantly
monitored they believe that is about to
come to an end
britney's father jamie was the original
controller of the conservatorship but
he's now been removed and says it should
end immediately without a medical
evaluation as would usually be the case
many conservatorship experts think this
points to the end
and there is no opposition to the
conservatorship ending for the first
time in 13 years all the parties
involved be it britney her attorney the
court representatives her father
her conservator jody montgomery all are
in agreement that the conservatorship
should end and thus there's no
opposition it will be over
even if the conservatorship is
terminated this isn't the final chapter
britney and her lawyers say they'll
fight to find the full depths of how her
life was controlled for so long martha
calmner sky news los angeles
hello again everybody watching breakfast
program here on sky news welcome back to
cop 26. today was supposed to be the
final day for world leaders who have
gathered here to come up with some plans
on how we can keep temperature warming
to 1.5 degrees above the levels that
they were in 1880. it's looking more and
more likely that that is not going to be
concluded today will it be reached um
tomorrow the prime minister of the
bahamas he's been talking to us and he's
warned most people in this country could
become refugees unless a deal to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions is agreed here
in glasgow his name philip davis and he
was speaking to uh marxon
if you're lucky
um we may become refugees
if you are not lucky
you'll be swallowed up with the rising
sea levels
or wiped away by
more and more intense storms
we will be speaking
and we will be speaking to um a climate
campaigner in just a few moments time
from the guardian before that though
let's bring in um rob powell no
government minister today rob they tell
us they are on recess we'll be speaking
to labour a little bit later on and also
to nicola sturgeon she'll be joining us
uh the first minister of scotland just
after uh eight o'clock a lot of pressure
on the prime minister though
yeah and i think this was always going
to be a very difficult task for
whichever prime minister whichever
country hosted um this climate
conference i think getting countries
like china to come to the table
and make meaningful cuts in their
ambitions in terms of emissions and
getting other countries to scale back um
on their use of coal was always going to
be tough that's why alex sharma the cop
president
had been clocking up the miles ahead of
this conference to sort of try and roll
the pitch
for meaningful concessions in glasgow
now has that worked well in terms of the
first week you could maybe make an
argument that it had to some extent i
think there was some optimism from the
uk side i think they were pleasantly
surprised um the sort of sense of
momentum um going through that first
week with those agreements around
deforestation involving brazil
and agreements on methane as well i
think it's when we got into the second
week
and actually the sort of meat of the
issue where
it all seemed to get a little bit more
gloomy and i think that is because some
of the fundamentals here
in terms of the fundamental positions of
various countries don't seem to have
changed and i think reading that draft
agreement and there will be more it will
be revised you can see why the prime
minister of the bahamas feels quite so
pessimistic because there is a lot of uh
what uses of words like urges and
emphasizes and recognizes and i think
that is why people like the prime
minister of the bahamas say that they
want something
a lot more concrete and of course an
argument even over
whether um there should be uh a
reference to coal and fossil fuels in
there as well uh i think publicly you're
getting gloomy signals as well the u.n
secretary general antonio guterres
saying that the keep 1.5 alive um target
is really on life support alex sharma
saying that window is closing i think if
the ambition for this summit as stated
was to conclusively say that that 1.5
degree target has been kept alive i
think it's looking more and more
unlikely by the end of glasgow that they
will be able to say that so for boris
johnson and the uk government it may
well prove that this conference doesn't
live up to the lofty ambitions set out
for it
okay rob thanks very much indeed lucky
to have with us uh george monbiot
guardian columnist and environmental
activist good morning to you now you've
been here throughout haven't you we've
just had a document that's been released
quite a weighty to tome do we know
anything about it at this stage i
haven't yet had a chance to look at it i
dare say it's going to be another
incomprehensible word salad similar to
the previous ones that they've released
um there's this sense that they are
still just messing about at the margins
of this you know we need
really striking fundamental change like
i i promise to leave fossil fuels in the
ground no more fossil fuels by 2030.
that's the scale of what needs to happen
by contrast it's just all in square
brackets at the moment it's all
just messing about with little details
this is not going to get us out of the
fix that we're in how do you think
that cop 26 will go down in history
well there's so far been 24 failed
summits and half a successful one paris
in 2015 this unfortunately is looking
very much as if it's going to be the
25th failed
i think that is is it because of
countries like australia particularly
russia china and brazil who are paying
lip service but actually when it comes
to it i'm not taking the steps needed
well we can all point to each other as
being responsible for this and indeed
certain countries yeah much more
recalcitrant than others but actually
there is a generalized lack of political
will you know the host nation here the
uk
has done some reasonable things for
climate but it's just not got the will
to drive this process through there's no
ambition i mean where are the ministers
today you know right in the middle of
this this crucial climate conference
boris johnson goes and creates a
political scandal and draws all the
oxygen away from it so there's there's
no necessarily mean to do that well no
but i mean he was he got so he went off
on one trying to save owen patterson by
creating this
thing and and of course you know that
was bound to blow up it was bound to
block he should have been relentlessly
focused on this issue because
let's face it everything else becomes
irrelevant beside it if we don't get
this right you know we're talking about
the collapse of our life support systems
so all our hopes all our fears all our
ambitions all our dreams all our loves
all our hates
they're always thistle down by
comparison to this huge crashing issue
it could happen very quickly we don't
know because we're dealing with complex
systems and complex systems have tipping
points
and as
and if they're pushed past a critical
threshold they will go very quickly
indeed it's 1.5 degrees
we don't know we don't know i mean 1.5
degrees is an arbitrary figure to be
honest you know obviously we want to
keep heating as low as we possibly can
and so that's what they've come up with
as an arbitrary figure is it safe well
we don't know i mean the only safety is
safer than 2.4 degrees um which
apparently is very concerning and and
could be what we are landing at at the
moment that that at the moment seems to
be the thrust of where we're heading for
which is probably an extremely dangerous
level of global heating um
but we because we don't know where the
tipping points lie you know the only
really safe approach is sudden and
drastic change where we say right we're
just going to cut off fossil fuel supply
and bring about a transition as rapid
as the us underwent when it joined the
second world war at the end of 1941
within a few months to turn the entire
economy from civilian to military we
need to turn our entire economy from
fossil powered to clean energy what
about this oil field that's shetland
it's i mean it is amazing that we're
still talking about developing new oil
fields to pull more fossil fuels out of
the ground the the fundamental task here
is leaving fossil fuels in the ground
and it's an extraordinary indictment of
all 26 cop conferences that not one of
them has taken that seriously and has
highlighted that as the issue we need to
deal with beside that everything else is
distraction it's just all hand waving
and grandiloquent gestures and and fine
words but unless you're actually
committed to leaving those dirty fuels
in the ground you are
therefore going to be committed to
further global heating and catastrophe
uh just before i let you go what are we
sitting on uh it's paper of some kind
yeah because correct attention to that i
don't know if you can see it and until i
sat down it's like some sort of
corrugated paper or something definitely
recycled i mean they've certainly
paid lip service here some might say um
but unless they actually get a deal then
it was all for nothing well yeah i mean
i mean they're very good at dressing it
up although it has to be said that some
delegates have described this to me as
the worst organized climate conference
they've ever been to yeah absolutely
killed it not even enough chairs for
example but you know much more important
things delegates who have flown halfway
around the world can't get into crucial
meetings um it's it's been catastrophic
in that respect but not nearly as
catastrophic as a totally feeble outcome
which unfortunately is where it seems to
be heading okay george good to talk to
you thanks very much indeed thanks thank
you i'll just take that with you thank
you
um
tell me about these documents that have
just been released
yeah kay in the last few minutes the new
draft agreement has just dropped we've
had this from
uh the cop president alok sharma he has
said that well he said this document
shows us that the language mentioning
fossil fuels has changed but fossil fuel
subsidies is still mentioned within the
agreement if i just read it out to you
this is quite significant because let's
remember we've been talking today about
countries like saudi arabia like russia
like china thinking that initially it
was mentioned in the draft agreement but
could it well be phased out of the next
version of the agreement this is what it
says this is paragraph 20. now it calls
upon the party so all 197 parties who
are here at cop 26 to accelerate the
development deployment and dissemination
of technologies like green energy
technologies and the adoption of
policies to transition to low emission
energy systems including by rapidly
scaling up clean power generation and
this is the crucial bit accelerating the
phase out of unabated coal power and of
inefficient subsidies of fossil fuels
why is this significant well this is
significant because for the first time
this is the first time the united
nations deal any form of united nations
deal has mentioned the term coal or the
term fossil fuel subsidies that's what
we've all been waiting for across
past cops past conference of parties
it's often the case that when these
draft agreements are drawn up
often the um language changes over time
and often the draft agreement is very
different to the final thing so the fact
that the um the fact that this this most
recent document that we've been waiting
all hours or waiting for it it is now
here
uh thanks ashna chatting about that in
more detail throughout the course of the
program george has been distilling some
of that information for us as well from
the guardian uh of course um
headlines for you well they say they
want to phase out unabated coal and
fossil fuel subsidies which yeah it's
fine it's a slight improvement on the
previous draft
so it means unabated coal means um coal
power um coal-fired power stations which
are not capturing the carbon dioxide and
pumping it underground
and fossil fuel subsidies well at the
moment nations are pouring billions and
billions of trillions into um
subsidizing fossil fuels it's outrageous
so obviously
getting rid of those two things is a
very good thing but it's still nowhere
near
the fundamental simple policy we need
which is leaving all fossil fuels in the
ground
okay george for now thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot let's bring in uh
pretty good should we see um
the labour representative joining us uh
this morning shadow minister for
international development of course
hello to you i don't know whether you've
managed to digest any of the document
that we've just been talking about
unabated uh fossil fuels for one good
idea
good morning i mean i think the wording
is absolutely welcome but we're telling
other countries um to phase out
fossil fuel but actually we're flirting
with the idea
here in terms of coal mines
at home and of course you know this
can't happen for many developing
countries if we don't have the climate
finance because how are they going to
mitigate and adapt their economies if
they just don't have the financing so
this is welcome it's it's tighter
wording it's you know it's it's giving a
kind of a clearer commitment but
actually without the climate finance
it's going to be very very difficult to
deliver it
um
we were originally um led to believe
that uh the conference would end today
cop 26 would end today it may now go on
until tomorrow some might say where are
the most important
leaders political leaders that can help
put their heft behind this certainly
nicola sturgeon will be with us at eight
o'clock where is kyo starmer where's the
prime minister
well look absolutely i think you know we
wanted you know labour wants to see cop
26 um succeed glasgow was about you know
how are we going to when we leave
glasgow make sure that countries are got
very clear delivery plans that will keep
1.5 degrees alive we're nowhere near
where we actually needed to be to half
global emissions i think we've all seen
um
from the report that we're actually
going to be putting our planet on track
for a disastrous 2.4 degrees of warning
and i think it's really um concerning we
absolutely did not need to kick the can
down the road on the climate finance if
we want to keep developing countries on
site it's been a ten year commitment
that we just have not been able to
deliver i think this is really
devastating the fact that they've got to
wait to adapt to mitigate their
economies until 2023 and this is largely
because what we actually saw during the
pandemic
was the government in retreats it was
naval naval gazing it was cutting aid it
was cutting bilateral aid to vulnerable
climate countries cutting bilateral
programs that were disproportionately
affecting women and girls and then when
you go around to other countries saying
look we really need to step up we need
to get the 100 billion um in place
absolute laughingstock because this
government has tarnished our world
reputation we are the only g7 nations
who have cut aid and that meant we
didn't have the credibility
to really bring the broader coalition
and our allies together to say
this is the time to act now when i spoke
to global south activists from ghana
malawi across
africa what they were saying to me what
we don't want to see from this cop 26 is
just more warm words we really need to
see action and of course we just haven't
had that and i want the us and china to
back the call as the biggest emitters of
the developing countries to say
we can't delay closing the gap we've got
to come back every single year until we
can close that gap i think that's
absolutely right ed miliband has been
calling for that um you know i know the
cop 26 president alec trauma has really
been trying he's been up against it with
the treasury and with the prime minister
because you know our global reputation
being a trusted potter on the
international stage really does matter
how much has sleaze been a distraction
how much sorry
has sleaze and a distraction from cop26
i i think it's been a huge distraction
for the prime minister and nobody had
thought as the top 26 president that
there he would be actually on stage uh
you know saying
making a huge statement that britain is
not country absolutely white britain is
not a crop country but this prime
minister and this conservative
government are absolutely mired
in fleas and corruption and of course
this is not something that we are seeing
that is new this is not just last week
we have seen this consistently
throughout the pandemic with the issuing
of government contracts i think it's a
really uh concerning place to find
ourselves when i've been out on the door
talking to people it's the one thing
that they're saying that they absolutely
do not want
britain to be seen globally as well as a
country that doesn't uphold its
democratic values and principles it's
something that we've always been very
proud of and actually our reputation has
been absolutely tarnished by this um
conservative government
yeah but how nervous is the labour party
that there are similar revelations of
sleaze that could uh come and bite you
on your nose
look people will constantly be looking
for stories and i think this is not
about making this about politics this is
about the trust that we put
into our democracy into our parliament
and it's so important for people this is
what labour absolutely wants to bring
back by having an office office for
value for taxpayers money you know we're
saying that we've got to stop mps having
second jobs they've got to be absolutely
committed um to serving their
constituents they can't be legislators
and paid lobbyists at the same time it
just does not work that way um and we've
got to make sure that we have process in
place that enable mps to ensure that
they're not uh you know avoiding or
using loopholes in a way we expect the
rules for the country to be the same
rules for parliamentarians and that's
exactly what labour wants
just looking at another poll out this
morning second poll um in a row miss
gill and uh it's give it's a redfield
and uh wilton poll showing labor with a
two-point lead over the conservatives as
i said second poll in a row finally uh
labor does appear to certainly be
holding its own for now what are you
going to do to hold on to that
well i think we've been a credible
opposition we've seen it through the
pandemic where i think all of us have
lost count how many u-turns we've
managed to get the government to um it's
absolutely getting cut through the fact
that labour is being able to hold the
government to account but it's also been
able to provide some very clear
solutions we're not just coming uh and
saying what the government's got wrong
we're actually saying well this is what
the government could do this is the
alternative just like we set out the
five-point plan uh for cop 26 as well
in terms of what we expected so uh
absolutely uh you know we are going to
continue to do uh the work that we've
been doing setting out the policies on
the side of working people and building
that trust back back into politics
that's exactly what is needed right now
i'm going to go this way
okay it's good to talk to you ms gill
thank you very much indeed for taking
the time to join us on the programme
this morning last day of uh the climate
summit here in glasgow or is it i'm just
going to go this way headley will go
around the other way um i just want to
show you the climate dashboard you know
that the prime minister has been saying
throughout let's keep 1.5 alive and 1.5
is the temperature that we do not want
to go above 1880 levels in order to try
to have a fighting chance to keep
control of our planet this is our
boxing ring as you can see this is where
we have our special programme that is on
throughout the climate live show uh
global warming since
1881.23 degrees above the level that it
was in 1880. this scary figure here this
is the millions of tons of carbon
dioxide emissions
that is being spewed out into the
atmosphere that according to the
university of oxford
this is the real-time power mix for the
renewables at the moment pretty windy up
here in glasgow and other parts of the
uk and as a result 46.3 percent as an
example for you is uh how much uh wind
power is being used to power the uk
right now interestingly here down at the
bottom um coal
nothing at all and solar hardly
surprising because it's not a very sunny
day but there you go nothing from sun
other sun either but certainly coal is
way down it's not the case in all
countries and that is what we need to
see in order to bring this figure down
and that is what we're talking about
here in glasgow will we have a
resolution by the end of the day
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
friday will start mild and windy with
spells of heavy rain in the north and
west that rain will spread across more
of britain during the morning but it
won't amount to much in the south
meanwhile northern ireland will turn
drier and brighter strong winds will
bring coastal gales to parts of the west
the afternoon we'll see the wind and
rain easing giving some late brightness
in places
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
are expected to remain low measuring
between one and three on the daily air
quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
i'm talking about the smaller countries
in the past hour here on sky news and
the impact that it might have on them
unless we can agree
1.5 degrees by the end of the cop 26
climate sunlit uh we talked
about the bahamas didn't we but we also
want to tell you about what's happening
with madagascar landscape is under
threat there from illegal mining is what
we're being told our special
correspondent alex crawford is there for
us
they're digging for gems which they hope
will change their lives forever and haul
them out of poverty
trouble is the last time they found
anything of any note was eight months
ago a piece of barrel they sold for two
millionaires about 500
split amongst the team of seven not
exactly the fortune they're dreaming of
happened is it broken
now for sure he'll be having trouble
breathing his colleague tells us as the
team tries to patch together the
lifeline with tape
underground the break in the air supply
is rapidly noticed
but the lack of panic seems to indicate
this is a fairly regular potentially
deadly hazard they often pass out down
here but it doesn't put them off
and we'll be chatting to alex in the
next hour here on sky news our special
coverage from cop 26 here in glasgow as
i've been saying all morning will they
reach a deal by the end of the day ashna
has been looking at some documentation
that's been released tell me more we
have been waiting all night for this
documentation but it's arrived in the
last few moments or so the key phrase we
were looking out for was fossil fuels
because there's a clause written in the
very first draft that said they wanted
to phase out fossil fuel subsidies and
coal now a lot of parties including the
saudis saudi arabia kicking up a bit of
a fuss about it we heard in the
background but it looks as though that
wording has remained within the draft
agreement as within within the latest
draft agreement so it looks as though
that's staying in the wording however
has very much changed the language
around it things like they're going to
phase out insufficient fuel fossil fuel
subsidies and unabated coal power well
exactly it's up to up for interpretation
and i think that's the key thing
regarding these documents is the
language around it will be so important
because each nation is going to take it
however they want to take it so what
actually happens with a minute left on
the show what actually happens there are
officials who will sign these documents
the leaders have to come and sign it
what happens so it's one final huge
document it's very complicated at the
moment it's covered in loads of brackets
and those vitalik fonts what is
currently happening is every single
nation so every single 197 parties has
to agree on the terms the exact wording
and phrasing so that's what they're uh
that's what's all in the air so they all
have to sign it they each have to agree
on every single word so it's no wonder
it's taking ages oh okay
let's see if we can unpick that uh by
the end of the program for now thanks
very much indeed so ashley's saying we
have had this document it is 46 pages
long i think she's had 46 pages yeah she
did um but what does it actually say
what does it actually mean will these
leaders be signing that and their
representatives by the end of play today
that's what is slated to happen could it
go into another day continuing coverage
here on skype